صلاح المغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعطف على الفقراء اوصل منتخب بلاده الى
قمه افريقيا وصار اسطوره حيه في السنغال
[موسيقى]
ساديو
مسلمه جنوب السنغال عام 1992
وعاش في بيت عمه لعدم قدره والديه على
اعالته بسبب الفقر وكثره اخوانه وافراد
العائله ثم فقدانه لوالده وهو في سن
السابعه
بدا ممارسه كره القدم المبكرا في ساحات
القريه الفقيره احب الطفل هذه اللعبه وراى
فيها ملاذا ينهض باسرته ويخلصها من الفقر
ويضمن له المجد والشورى حزم امتعته وهرب
دون علم احد الى داكار في سن الخامسه عشر
متقدما بحدائه الممزق لاختبارات القبول
لدى احد الانديه
في ارجاء العاصمه اختاره كشافه نادي الماس
في الدرجه الثانيه وحملوه معهم الى فرنسا
لم يصدق الطفل الصغير ان حلمه بدا يتحقق
وان الكره اوفت بعهدها ووضعته في طريق
العالميه بدا يومه الاول مذهولا وطلب من
مصور النادي التقاط صوره لها كي يرسلها
لوالدته التي لم تصدق ان صغيره النخيل صار
لاعبا في اوروبا
طويل
[موسيقى]
النمسا انتقل الى نادي
الجناح حصد معه عده القاب قبل ان ينتقل
الى المهدي كره القدم واقوى دورياتها
لاعبا في صفوف نادي سلطنه بمبلغ 14 مليون
يورو
خاضعه موسمين وسجل في احدى المباريات
هاتفيك في ثلاث دقائق فقط وقعت عليه عين
مدرب ليفربول الالماني يورجن كلوب وجد فيه
كل خصائص المهاجم التي تناسب طريقته جناح
مهاري خارج السرعه يجيد اللعب بقدميه
اليمنى واليسرى على حد سواء
الدفاعات بتحركاته الذكيه
كان عند حجم التوقعات المرجوبه منها
[تصفيق]
محمد صلاح
بعد سنوات من شح الالقاب وكانت قوام
الفريق الذي غزا اوروبا وحقق البطولات
اصيب بخيبه امل في ايامه الاخيره مع الردز
بعد ان وضعت لاداره تجديد عقد صلاح اولويه
بالنسبه لها متجاهله اياه من دون تقديم
عرض جديد لاستمراره
ما دفعه للانتقال الى بايرن ميونخ ليبدا
رحله جديده
[موسيقى]
نال منزله خاصه في قلوب الجمهور السنغالي
توج مع المنتخب بلقب افريقيا للمره الاولى
بتاريخه
وساهم في تاهله الى مونديال كاس العالم
بقطر عام 2022 ونال لقب افضل لاعب افريقي
في مناسبتين اخرهما العام الجاري اشتهر
باعماله الخيريه ومساعدته لابناء قريته
وبلده
وقدم المساعدات للفقراء ومبلغ 45,000
€ لمساعده المصابين في السنغال ووزع 300
قميص لنادي ليفربول لسكان قريته لمشاهده
النهائيه ابطال اوروبا عام 2019 الذي كان
احد اطرافه
نال مؤخرا جائزه سقراط ضمن حفل الكره
الذهبيه المخصصه لتكريم لاعبي كره القدم
المناضلين من اجل اندماج وحمايه المناخ
والمحرومين
انتشر له مقطع فيديو وهو ينظف حمامات احد
مساجد ليفربول
فعذب صوره اللاعب الخلوق المحفوره في
اذهان الجمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]